Jonah Hill Jonah Hill's alleged
controversial Behavior Steve Harvey I
believe it was I don't have female
friends I don't I'm I'm incapable of
that more and more even celebrities
gravitating towards Islam they see that
solution for all their problems after I
tell you if I was a woman I don't want
to be wow I'm ready
I'm ready and then women can't be
friends a few of my different guy
friends
and on a hill it's like he's almost
talking as if he's a Muslim that's it
that's it yeah I mean you can have guy
friends no you can't she would uh do
very good also with looking into Islam
so we give them both an invitation
listen I mean Society has deceived a lot
of women about what they need to be
happy and I'll tell you this is
[Applause]
alive
peace be upon him this is our religion
Islam Islam this is the beach
and I was explaining how much respect I
have for the faith
[Music]
Jonah Hill Jonah Hill's alleged
controversial behavior is being exposed
by his former partner Sarah Brady who is
sharing a plethora of old text messages
that she claims are from him
through her public Instagram account
Sarah is leaving no stone unturned in
her depiction of Jonah as a toxic and
misogynistic partner brothers and
sisters we've all had loved ones that
passed away a mother a father brother
sister a close family member for one of
the mercies of our Dean is that with the
right intention we can go ahead and
continue to do good deeds on our loved
ones behalf and what greater of a
continuous Good Deeds
than investing on their behalf in the D
Center and Masjid and nagada Center that
will benefit generations to come
inshallah so click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you you heard of him absolutely I
just I'm just hearing about him it's all
over you know you can't log in and right
it's on the internet all over the place
is this Jonah Hill the mob's after him
yeah but he what is he like uh I guess
he's a he's an actor he's an actor a lot
of comedies yeah comedian or actor and
no no I think he's an actor I don't know
I don't know I don't follow him that
closely but I know he's a popular actor
starting a lot of comedic films but but
they're really coming after him right
now yeah I wanted to give a breakdown to
this because when you look into the I
guess what happened was he had a
girlfriend and years ago years ago and
then she leaked some of the private text
message between them they're supposed to
be private between them
and seems like that's the sanctity of
that was just broken and then he got
into a relationship I don't know if he
got married or he got he just had a
child but these texts were from some
time ago but we look at the text
we want to contrast it with what Islam
says right is this something that is uh
Halal Haram how would you he's getting
blasted for these texts yeah and when I
read them I was shocked because his
message is what any person of Honor Any
Man Of Honor may ask of a significant
other and and frankly I mean he was just
so soft about it he said listen uh you
know if we're going to be in a
relationship these are my boundaries
these are my expectations and if this
isn't okay with you then listen no hard
feelings I will always respect you you
know we can stay friends but it's just
not going to work out as a relationship
I mean what else is a guy supposed to do
apparently you can't even uh communicate
uh basic expectations of morality and
decency and it's it's crazy because at
the same time right now you have online
some guy getting a lot of Fame uh
because apparently he filmed his wife
sleeping with another man fornicating
with another man making pornography with
another man and you don't see him
getting targeted and attacked by the
woke mob it's sickening and disgusting
but here you have a man just telling his
girl Hey listen you know and I think
he's from a Jewish background so
consistent with sort of Jewish
principles you know you're Jonah Hill I
believe so if I'm not mistaken uh you
know your your girl shouldn't be out
there half naked for the world to see
and he's just set very basic standard
saying listen you know if we're in a
relationship uh you know I would
appreciate it if you you know were um
modest in this in this fashion and if
not listen uh I respect you and I
respect your choice and he's getting
blasted for that it's crazy we're going
to go through these one by one because
there's kind of like a point by Point
what he's asking right of he's kind of
like uh almost like vetting her like
okay if you fulfill these requirements
so if you go ahead and you're in sync
with what I'm saying then we can move
forward exactly an honest dialogue about
what he's looking for in a partner but
but let's even before we get to that all
right before we get to the actual text
message that was leaked out there let's
get into this thing and then contrast
with what the dean says with Islam says
because about privacy because now one
one side of the you're an attorney for
people that know with shibbling Shibley
legal.org muslimlegal.org
how does this now play into the legal
are there any legal consequences now
when two people this is they were dating
they weren't married and now years ago
you think okay I'm having a conversation
with you and now he's out here on trial
because somebody went and and
obviously they want some clout you know
what I mean angry
vindictive and now they're put in a
private conversation out there for the
world well you know what who's going to
pay the price of this is ultimately the
woman that do this they're going to be
paying the price in this I think you're
going to see a world where there's going
to be a lot of miserable 40 and 50 year
old single woman because this concept of
respecting a relationship respecting men
respecting privacy uh is is dying I
think modern you know feminism frankly
wants a world where women have authority
without responsibility you know the man
should still pay for the dinner he
should still pay for the bills he should
still open the car door but he should
not be entitled to any respect
whatsoever so my modern feminism wants
to give women Authority without
responsibility and wants to give men
responsibility without Authority that is
against the fitral that is against human
nature that's a recipe for disaster so
what's ultimately going to happen is you
have a lot of bitter single women in
their 30s 40s and 50s meanwhile the guys
alhamdulillah they recover good you know
if they're honest if they're
straightforward if they're honorable if
they're traditional there's a lot of
women out there even younger women that
appreciate traditional men who say you
know what I'm a masculine man I want you
to be a feminine woman you I will take
care of you financially I will protect
you I will honor you I will have a
healthy level of jealousy for you you
know this concept of rira right this
this kind of jealousy that you don't
want other men looking at your wife's
behind you don't want other men gawking
at your wife's physical features you
know that's against honor that's against
dignity so what's going to happen is
people Men of Honor they're gonna find
those that are seeking honor and all
these uh people that are disrespecting
privacy disrespect acting modesty
they're going to end up alone single
miserable and toxic but I'm glad you
mentioned this point of privacy because
what's happening now it's very popular
it becomes a thing if you have a
relationship with a successful man and
it doesn't work out for any reason
you know years later come back when you
see him happy and successful and you're
feeling irrelevant he just had a child
exactly he's moved on with his life you
know there's no allegations of physical
violence there's no credibility to such
allegations and just come out and
disclose private conversations and blast
him and frankly what kind of message
does that send every future potential
partner do you think now the next person
who's gonna try to have a relationship
with this woman is ever going to trust
her you know it's it's destructive it's
again sometimes the prophecy the prophet
saw Allah Islam is perfect and I think
this is why you're finding more and more
even celebrities
gravitating towards Islam they see that
solution for all their problems Prophet
sallam said
conversations are a sacred trust when
there's two conversations between people
whether they're over text message
whether they're in person that is a
confidential trust there's a level of
privilege and confidentiality and you
can't just simply disclose that
especially when there's really no reason
to I mean it's crazy when you read the
message you see this is what people were
freaking out over but the fact that
years after relationship ended she feels
it's appropriate to disclose those
messages for what end for what purpose
There's no practical justifiable benefit
other than to get attention to play
victim I think people get addicted to
being victim they want to be the victim
they want attention they want to attack
the man you know it just it's sad and
it's destructive
yeah that reminded me of the what you
just uh Hadith which you quoted you know
the sanctity now of privacy the imana
the trust so much so that as soon as you
this is clearly laid out in Islam where
you're talking to someone and this is
all from the guidance of the Creator the
department
you're talking to someone as soon as
you're finished talking with someone and
you turn to the other direction that
imana is in a lock that's it it doesn't
go like you know we see we hear that you
know obviously the term for our audience
that don't Nema I mean
caring Tails carrying Tales right he
said she said right as soon as you talk
one conversation then you go and pass to
the next
person won't enter you know people are
hearing this term yes so this is Haram
clearly this is something that even this
backbiting slandering and then we can
give the Hadith where the companion the
um disciples Companions of prophet
Muhammad they said what is backbiting he
says to say something about your brother
that he would dislike they say what if
it's true that's backbiting still it's
even true but he would dislike his
backbiting what if it's not true is
slander slander it's even worse it's
even worse but both are terrible this is
clear you don't have this I mean in any
I mean this is clearly laid out that you
can't get this fumble over this is so
straightforward in Islam absolutely
absolutely I think people are a loss
formality and they're they're creating
an environment where ultimately they're
gonna pay the price you know as you deal
with others so you will be dealt with
you know you disclose personal private
text messages it's going to come back
and people are gonna do the same to you
people are not gonna trust you you're
going to lose yourself it's a shame all
right let's get into the uh text here
let's read it let's see what's so bad
about it let's see what all right shook
the woke mob online so the question is
is he inviting like the other guy
inviting someone to go ahead and have a
swinging party with his wife is he
inviting someone to go ahead have a
taste test or he's setting some setting
some lines here so he says plain and
simple he's like plain and simple
if you need surfing number one surfing
with men so let's go Point by more it's
surfing with men so you can play this
with any other sport right so
islamically now we have the separation
of genders and whatnot the free misks
mixing this is something really clear
but now surfing you know going pretty
much being what comes to my mind you
could take it is the
um you know where the Prophet saws said
when a when a man is alone with a woman
shaytan is the third right so this is so
what are your thoughts now number one
surfing with men right right I mean look
again the whole concept of Surfing
you're you're scantly cloudy dressed you
know you're you're dressed in a very in
modest fashion with others that are
dressed in very in modest fashion Islam
recognizes human nature let's cut the BS
out this have there's so much hypocrisy
right and this is the problem with with
the Western culture is it it mixes so
much hypocrisy for example Western
culture claims monogamy but it free
mixes so much that no one is really
monogamous it's right they're cheating
they're committing adultery they're
they're consuming record amounts of
pornography it's such hypocrisy if you
look it's just human nature biological
nature when men see more skin of women
women see more skin of men the uh
testosterone levels the the chemical
levels they're going to rise in the body
it's going to lead to Temptation people
are going to get themselves in in very
inappropriate situations so some says
protect yourself don't don't don't test
yourself like that don't don't play with
fire stay away I mean the Bible itself
the Bible says you know don't Kindle
that fire lest you get burned uh the the
Quran doesn't say don't fornicate it
says Don't Go Near fornication even the
steps that lead to fornication avoid
protect protections and safeguards
because it recognizes the weakness of
human nature and therefore it Advocates
taking levels of protection against it I
like what you said protect yourself
don't test yourself yeah protect
yourself don't test yourself yeah we
don't have to get into the 20 plus
million diseases that are out there
yearly new ones come in uh the aborted
children now all these things right
write the X because the person doesn't
know his these are all the protection
that Islam puts straight forward so you
don't fall into any of these things you
destroy Society because now you've
destroyed the home you couldn't even
build the home because now you're out
there fornicating because you went and
you started to uh surf with men it's
it's it's it's problematic so again it
starts with the concept of modesty
should there be a level of modesty
between men and women and how they dress
and how they interact all the all the
religions have advocated for that I like
what you said cut the baloney yeah cut
the nonsense let's keep it PG I mean
because if a man's surfing I don't know
if this he's next to you surfing with
you got these Big Sur whatever the case
and he's seeing you dressed pretty much
in your underwear in the swimsuit well
they have this false level that he
shouldn't be thinking of the body you
know he shouldn't just see me as an
object like that okay he shouldn't but
people are people you know what I'm
saying I mean the the power of sexuality
is very powerful right I mean the human
needs to procreate this is how God made
us and and he warned us all right Don't
Go Near it yeah so there's no way unless
the man is um part of the alphabet
movement Maybe
uh he's got some kind of uh maybe
something's wrong with him he's
naturally going to be included he's
going to wake up he his uh his desires
are going to be he's going to be better
he's normal if he's healthy and if she's
got something that is appealing to him
he's going to be burning would you say
absolutely listen how would you play
desired burning it's like I mean what is
it it's the listen and those who know
and if you don't know uh you're you're
just kidding yourself look the desire to
have intimate relations Is deeply
ingrained within healthy human beings
right human beings whose body has not
been corrupted by chemicals by toxins by
society and that's a good thing right we
should want to procreate we should want
to have kids we should want to build
families we should want to build tribes
right uh in a healthy conducive way
but when there isn't a protection of
modesty you know when everyone is
dressed naked in public you know you
have an increase in Temptation those are
just facts and that's why you have
record amounts of adultery in the west
all right so Jonah Hill actually is
asking for something uh Halal right
all right let's keep it going and you
know look Eddie the biggest counter to
that is going to be like well he knew
she was a surfer when he got into it
well that's fine okay and now the
relationship is growing and he seems to
be one take it in a serious Direction so
he's communicating and that's perfectly
fine what better thing is there than to
communicate yeah that's a good point you
brought up because at the end of the day
and the reason another reason we're
doing this because at the end we want to
give both of them an invitation
invitation to what you'll see at the end
because now where is he going to go
because he's going with his his nature
his nature his Society is cutting that
off and making him feel like he's you
know he's so misogynist
narcissists right yeah right so where
are you going to go to fit Islam well
they're calling him an abuser and that's
the crazy thing now this is abuse it's
it they've made abusive joke listen I'm
an attorney I represent actual victims
of abuse and when you throw out that
label to text messages like this you're
dishonoring the many actual victims that
are out there yeah it is crazy uh next
one boundaries
inappropriate friendships with men okay
so that's the next Point here well I
mean boundary list
inappropriate friendships with men yeah
nobody cheats on their significant other
generally from the get-go like that it
doesn't start like that right except for
those that just go to the bar go to the
club start drinking and end up going
home with someone else God God forbid
but you know that's how these
relationships of adultery a fornication
of cheating start it's by having
inappropriate relationships uh you know
there's this whole thing about having a
guy best friend there's no such thing as
you having a guy best friend outside of
your spouse and I think in fact the
Tates uh mentioned this you know where
where one of them said to the girlfriend
Hey listen let me go ahead who do you
think uh is just your guy friend that's
not interested in you just text him that
me and you are having problems and that
you have feelings for them see how they
react and like every one of the guys
that were so-called just friends said oh
my god I've had feelings for you this
whole time you know yeah it's it's we're
just not designed like that all right
Steve Harvey he gave a great example
um and people this he's a comedian so it
seems like you know when they break it
in and then they'll just uh people kind
of um uh don't end up rejecting what
someone like his like like comedians can
tell the truth right the court testers
can often get away with it yeah so the
way he uh put it and we'll put it so
people can see this uh short clip with
uh Steve Harvey I believe it was I don't
have female friends I don't I'm I'm
incapable of that why what do you mean
well because you know come on because
you have a wife
well I have a wife and I don't I don't
really have female friends because look
you're an attractive woman there's some
guy somewhere saying yeah I'm we're
friends no that's not true he's your
friend only because you have made it
absolutely clear that nothing else is
happening except this friendship we have
we remain your friends in hopes that one
day there'll be a crack in the door a
in the armor and trust and believe
that guy that you think is just your
buddy he will slide in that crack the
moment he gets the opportunity
99.9 of us think that way and he made it
clear that men and women he just he says
it just and yeah
I just can't do it you can't you cannot
men and women can't be friends a few of
my different guy friends have revealed
to me that they have feelings for me and
I'm not interested but I'm just
wondering where this sudden Mojo came
from I mean do you notice anything
unique about me I don't know there's
nothing
I'm happily married you thought that
they really just wanted to be your
friend well yeah I mean you can have guy
friends no you can't only where you have
a guy friend is you're saying we're only
friends they're hanging out with you in
hopes of something else happening they
hang out with you and they circle like
buzzards waiting on a crack in the door
a in the armor guys are not made
that way men they don't hang out with
flag chicks to be their friend you hope
you catch them hurting one day and
you're there for them guys know I'm
telling you the truth exactly what you
just said because there'll be a crack
there'll be just a man is waiting Chris
Rock even talked about this years ago
you get put in the friend zone because
every man is trying to hook up but then
it doesn't work out they put you in the
friend zone but as soon as there's a
crack something happens he's waiting
he's a predator he's waiting for years
and then that's it he's in there that's
it so this now we can take this from
what he's saying to this uh for the
missile community in general for for the
young men out there for men in general
or for for women these are boundaries
that Allah has set and we need to
respect those boundaries and absolutely
listen as you grow and it's it's an
interesting space to navigate maybe when
you're younger you're trying to be more
conservative you're not free mixing and
then as you grow older you're getting
exposed to the professional world you're
finding you're having to because of work
and and responsibilities but then as you
grow wiser and more successful you
become very guarded with your time yeah
where you give your energy what is even
the point of friendship unless it's
increasing you spiritually
intellectually financially there's no
time for for any other sort of
friendship right there out there
um and frankly look I mean I think any
why successful man will know uh that
Haram is not worth it and even Halal you
know we don't have that much time even
for Halal relationships to be honest I
mean we we have a mission to accomplish
um so we just wise men and women cut out
unnecessary distractions you know
there's a there's a funny meme going out
there right that the financial advice
for men and there's a lady walking down
the street and the man just go the other
way but but if your principles and
you're focused you're not going to let
uh the opposite gender in in your life
in a way that's not uplifting you in
this life and the next and that's what
we should seek as Believers we should
see excellence in this life and the next
and if the kinds of people you keep
around you the kinds of relationships
you have are not uplifting you in both
worlds and they're a drag so look I
think for him to to tell his potential
spouse because it looks like he's
looking for something serious that you
know there shouldn't be any
inappropriate relationships with the
opposite gender again he's setting a
very natural and healthy boundary that
frankly women that haven't been
corrupted by the feminist experiment
that has failed would naturally
gravitate to I mean uh in fact I mean
there's a lot of woman would be upset if
their husband didn't have a healthy
level of jealousy if he was to take it
to the next level and he became a Muslim
and he accepted Islam
mation to the Creator not the creation
and he ended up making these uh
this is something that's outlined in
Islam really clear I mean if a husband
has every right to pretty much almost
pick and choose or to object to certain
people having having influence over his
wife absolutely this is strongly clear
because they have responsibility you
cannot have responsibility without
Authority any relationship any Dynamic
that gives someone responsibility
without Authority is a recipe for
disaster it's a recipe for failure
frankly it's a recipe for rage why do
you think you have so many problems
right now uh and conflicts within
households when there's responsibility
without Authority so you know Authority
gives you the means to achieve your
responsibility right the man is
responsible for the safe keeping of the
home he's responsible for the financial
success he's responsible for the future
and and all that he needs a healthy
level of authority say listen I'm
responsible for the safety so I'm going
to set certain limits and boundaries and
look as you as the woman you have the
right to choose
whether you want to subject yourself to
my authority right nobody can force you
to marry me right nobody can force her
to to be with Jonah or not to view them
but if she's choosing to be with him
then there needs to be a level of
surrender I actually just saw Anonymous
woman I mean she did a very powerful
video about the concept of being just
submissive and and there's a whole
rejection of that nowadays but look as a
woman you have the right to choose who
do you want to be your protector who do
you want to submit to but once you've
chosen that and you and you given the
responsibility of leading your household
to success you have to be willing to
submit to him let him lead you so the
the husband is the leader of the family
he's the one that's responsible as the
uh the Quran beautifully State Allah is
saying save yourselves and your families
from the Hellfire right right so every
man is a shepherd of his family the
shepherd He will be responsible and he's
a responsible responsibility and he will
be questioned and it is a burden and it
isn't easy it's not a thing of power
Authority you know again I think the
Tate said this again you know there were
no feminists on the Titanic you know
they were no none of them saying no no
don't send the women and children first
you know men and women are the same or
equal not cut that nonsense out none of
them were crying about that when men had
to go out there and and fight in wars
and uh Hunt and Gather I mean this is
all the result of the modern Community
yeah yeah modern convenience so I want
to just before I go to the next one if
we go deeper into this if you look at
and just make some examples where people
can understand let's say somebody was
trying to get their life together and
they used to be
um and it's an extreme example but I'm
sure people are going to relate they
were really heavily into
methamphetamines or crack cocaine right
now so they had a certain group of
friends now you love this friend of
yours and now you you went through you
you if they hang out with certain people
they're gonna end up back into that
lifestyle of drugs right so you're as a
leader you don't want your children
hanging out with certain people or or
your spouse or your loved one or your
friend you see so that's one example but
now we take it to another level if you
are the responsible for your for your
family for your wife and somebody let's
say she she came to Islam she used to be
in the nightclub he used to be in the
nightclub you wouldn't want him either
hanging around certain friends who are
still drinking smoking weed or whatnot
so just a few different examples because
you want the best for your wife
he said that a person is on the religion
of their companions be careful yeah uh
who you keep companionship with and the
husband is also responsible for the
safety and the secure of that household
yeah you know so you know be careful who
you entrust to be your leader but once
you've identified a leader nothing will
give you more peace of mind than
actually surrendering to him and letting
him lead and this applies to the husband
and wife relationship but it also
applies to organizational Dynamics
company Dynamics business Dynamics uh
you can't thrive in chaos and Anarchy
you know that's satanic chaos and
Anarchy is satanic you need structure
you need to order the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he even advised if
three people are traveling together one
of them should be appointed the Emir
should be responsible and he said listen
and obey to your leader you know no
matter who he is once you have a leader
there needs to be a level of structure
because Satan thrives off of chaos yeah
so I think people can understand that
you want the best for your family so you
don't want if you know this is this
particular person is a thief a liar this
person is going to have a negative
influence over my family then you have a
right to object to this absolutely right
absolutely so that those are just some
examples and frankly if you don't trust
your husband in making those decisions
why did you marry him in the first place
you know it just doesn't make sense let
alone now let's take let's bring it back
to Jonah Hill
uh let alone to having friendships with
men who at the end of the day a bunch of
friends who at the end of the day what's
on their mind is how they're going to
hook up with you literally right
literally and not to mention then the
alcohol the intoxicants the whole
culture you know the hookup culture the
Friends with Benefits culture yeah um
it's it's sick what's out there yeah so
uh Jonah Hill is actually uh doing what
goes with the uh nature of men well
that's what's powerful I mean and let's
keep going through his message but one
of the things that struck out is you
know he's speaking from what we call in
the Islamic tradition the fitra the pure
nature that God put within us which is
what Islam came to reinforce and to
protect and to enrich and strengthen and
Empower so he's really reflecting I
think what a traditional person of Faith
who surrenders to God would believe as
it comes to modesty and and dignity and
honor and respect and that's what I
think the modern secular liberal culture
is trying to destroy and is rebelling
against and it's destroyed itself as a
result of that this is important that we
talk about this because now people who
have their fitra is still alive and it
hasn't been that tainted and they come
out and they're like okay what he's
doing there's nothing wrong with it but
now you have all the social media all of
the you know people are afraid to speak
out they're scared to speak I'm afraid
to speak out I mean one of the best
things that happened to me was getting
targeted and attacked by that group
because I saw them you know and it was
like a little you know they think
they're throwing big missiles at and
it's just like a little speck and
subhanallah you see men what are we
scared of you know uh only Allah can
cause us benefit or harm if you write by
Allah in your principled even the
attacks of your enemies will only
strengthen you and Supply witnessed that
in my own life and it was liberating and
now I'm in a position where I can
fearlessly speak out but even myself I
mean having been in the political world
I feel like if I didn't face those
attacks and see how insignificant they
were maybe I might have been too weak to
speak out out of fear of that mob which
is like a paper tiger again they're loud
but they're insignificant and they're
irrelevant you want to touch upon that
for a minute because you tweeted
something and I thought it was really
profound that you actually
um you had a uh your departure from care
you didn't get fired no no no left on
good terms you had um you had a um
picture you posted or something where
they were what were they were um uh they
were
um sending you like some Love Actually
the ladies that run care Florida
mashallah amazing sisters dedicated
Sensations
just celebrating 10 years of my service
there they gave that to me a couple
months actually after I left they they
invited me to the office and they
recognized me with that it was very yeah
something about like the media how when
when you were free of any any
it was
crazy I mean it was crazy
I was literally targeted by again
secular liberal woke mob they took
baseless allegations yeah ignored the
evidence against them and just publish
them as fact and I have the text
messages when alhamdulillah the legal
process cleared my name literally
Vindicated my name exposed the falsehood
of it I texted them hey are you gonna
update your story
that I was Vindicated and the little
responses that everyone's best they're
not interested but you know what it
showed me they don't matter what they
saw was an effective masculine
traditional Muslim man serving the
community they wanted to make him
irrelevant cancel him destroy him XML
and subhanallah Allah says in the Quran
never think such attacks are bad for you
they're better for you and you're like
how is that possible but I'm looking I
was actually in a state of such
gratitude last night I was reflecting
over how alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
after leaving care my income went up
1200 percent wow my travels and public
speaking went up three four times
I'm traveling more than ever
alhamdulillah doing more charity work
than ever and literally making twelve
hundred percent more than I used to make
before and this would not have happened
had it not been for that attack that I
faced so if you trust Allah you'll see
that even these attacks that only enrich
you and make you stronger this is
important very important because people
who don't have the Quran as a Guiding
Light uh the Sunnah of the Prophet
Muhammad peace allows to be upon him the
clear guidance it's one thing you're
non-muslim and you fall into to these
things and even non-muslims who are who
are honorable who you know who actually
stood by your side yeah who had many but
now as a Muslim you that's a shame
because Allah tells you when fasic when
a person comes to you an untrusted
untrustworthy person comes to you with
news you better check it up yes
otherwise you're going to fall into sin
you're going to fall into
um and you'll harm the innocent without
without knowing and you will regret it
and then how are you going to end up you
know with all the the um the media
that's out there you know the majority
of this stuff is just out there
cessationalism
false truths mistruths misinformation
and they're just looking for headlines
well you know it's interesting last
night uh alhamdulillah was reflected I
mean this weekend alone we're doing
about eight programs to train the Muslim
Community how to live by the Quran and
stay out of Courts whether that's to
marriage in regards to divorce in
regards to avoiding divorce to begin
with in regards to business in regards
to Estate Planning and it happened a lot
of love and support within Community but
some random Anonymous account uh which
portrayed itself as a Muslim sister just
went on slandering me and I looked at
her reach you know
um and it was reaching like 10 people so
it doesn't cause me any harm whatsoever
I was gonna ignore it but then you know
what I did I privately messaged that
account I said listen if you're truly a
Muslim I'm not messaging you to protect
myself you literally can't harm me since
you guys attacked me to begin with my
life's never been better that's Allah's
promise but if you're truly a Muslim I'm
genuinely worried for you how are you
going to stand before Allah the faming
and slandering your Muslim brothers and
sisters that are trying their best we're
all imperfect but we're trying our best
to serve our faith to serve our
community not for a need but because we
need to give back because it's Our
obligation to give back how are you
stand before Allah so I said get your
facts straight all the stuff you're
saying is wrong here's why it's wrong
I'm not telling you this to protect
myself you literally can't harm it
you're insignificant in that regard but
it's to protect your own self because
Allah says you say things about your
brothers and sisters and you think it's
light but it's terrible in the sight of
Allah yeah and for people also when they
watch this they're not yet Muslims out
there and then they have gone maybe
through some similar they see family
members you know and the gossip and the
you know the slander and all that and
they're like you know people getting
away with this but you know when you see
the clear guide guidelines in Islam and
the severe penalty in the next life for
someone who dies upon this doesn't
repent doesn't Rectify their Affairs and
there's actually a particular place in
the Hellfire for the people that spread
the gospel slander mongers and so
non-muslim Caesar said wow man attack to
honor Islam comes to protect honor and I
I really want to reach out to the
brothers and sisters because because
many of them reach out to me both women
and men that are going through difficult
times where people are speaking ill of
them misrepresenting them putting them
down and I will tell you never give up
hope in the mercy of Allah
is only allowing this to happen to build
you to make you independent of caring
what other people think to give you
strength
right to teach you to trust in him right
the prophet's wife
she faced such slander Yusuf a messenger
of Allah he faced such slander the best
people have faced horrific slander
horrific defamation and you know what
it's okay if it hurts
you know it's okay I mean I remember
when I was going through it you know I
would see the train in New York City I
wished I could fall in front of it man I
didn't want to live
you know and the prophet saws said none
of you should wish for death because of
a hardship they face but at the same
time we're a human right when uh may
Allah be pleased with her when she uh
was pregnant with and he said with Jesus
Christ with the version uh uh pregnancy
of of Jesus Piece upon him she said I
wish I died before this because she was
afraid you know what her people would
say in the difficulties in the hardship
that it came with so sometimes Allah
will test you and you lose the sweetness
for this material life yeah but that's
the blessing of it because this world is
worthless and maybe Allah just wants to
remove its love from your heart and when
you're able to detach from this world
and to stop caring what people think and
say and to know that only Allah's
opinion matters that liberates you and
then the world goes from being in your
hand eventually it ends up being in your
heart and the other beautiful thing
about this is it transforms the
relationships in your life because you
will never forget the people that stood
by you you will never forget even the
new friendships you made after that the
people who didn't judge you by what
people said about you but who got to
know you for who you are and truly loved
you it builds sincere relationships in
your life and it shakes out the
Hypocrites from your life it's a gift
from Allah so for those that are facing
such tests listen it's all right for it
to hurt but keep your trust in Allah and
he will deliver you and he will Elevate
you and he's promised and I bear witness
to This Promise being true that he will
give you far better than what you've
lost and it will be a means of success
for it and you will look back and you
will not regret what you want through
alhamdulillah and I'm telling you I went
through some tough times brother I don't
regret it I'm grateful to Allah Allah
never disappoints those who keep their
trust in him and that's the key keep
good opinion of Allah keep your trust in
him
I am as my servant thinks of me if he
thinks good he will find good keep a
good opinion of Allah Allah is too kind
to disappoint those who keep their trust
in him and who keep a good opinion of
him alhamdulillah
moving along to Jonah Hill and the
accusations against him
and we left off with friendships so we
covered that no inappropriate friendship
and this is something that actually and
we can go deeper into this but we have a
lot more yeah move on so he's doing
something actually that's uh in line
with Islam pretty much right right right
right taking care of his uh his
leadership role responsibilities and the
next one he says about modeling to model
that's all it says to model so I'm
assuming this is uh again what is the
concept of modeling they that you
cheapen your body so much that it's used
to sell products that that every Tom
Dick and Harry gets to uh gawk at your
body gets to look at your body that is
the essence of
um again a cheapening a human being that
is the essence of harming a woman Islam
honors the body for both men and women
you know and and obviously I mean we
could go on a whole the rant on the the
the the problem with modern day modeling
and what it means and how the woman's
body is often used to sell products and
in doing so it cheapens it a very very
problematic so I think look any man of
dignity would not want his wife's body
to be commoditized you know yeah uh just
to be fair so if tomorrow and we'll
we'll go ahead and if same thing with
the brothers you know if a a Muslim man
shouldn't be out there in on
but this is particular to this woman
here but you have some sisters also who
will fall into this uh this mod putting
themselves out there and you know so
imitating and we I it reminds me of how
the the statement of prophet Muhammad
peace Allah and you know this Hadith
probably says um you will imitate the
people before you inch by inch hand span
by hand spay so much so if they went
into a lizard Hall you follow them so
this whole concept uh of modeling now
you just said it beautifully you know
putting yourself devaluing yourself and
and uh cheapening yourself right right
look I'm gonna be real with you as
Muslims in the West for too long we've
been afraid to say what our religion
actually teaches yeah
and it takes
other people coming out who are just
sick and tired of the secular hedonistic
culture craving what Islam has to offer
the world to remind us
that what we have is everything and we
should cherish it and value it and and
we're not here to appease anyone Islam
is perfect and beautiful if you have a
pure nature you're going to see that and
we welcome you and if you hate it well
that's your problem not ours so
rasulullah when he asks his companions
what is the best thing of a woman
and what was the result I believe it was
uh if I'm not mistaken his daughter one
of the one of the
uh righteous woman answered that no man
sees her and she sees no man modesty
right this concept of modesty modesty
it's and it's it's just been lost in our
time we've lost that big time huh and
and it's all been within the last few
decades it's even in the in in the
United States yeah modesty was something
that was sacred up until relatively
recently yeah it reminds me of a
statement from I think was Norman
ficklestein and he was um if I can quote
it correctly he said when the people
came to these lands in the beginning
and they were in three layers or more of
clothing clothed up and then they saw
the natives pretty much they thought
they were uncivilized they were
uncivilized and now we're uncivilized
and we're looking at the Muslims who are
layered up
yeah yeah very powerful and even within
the the Bible the Quran
this concept of of sin and modesty so
it's interesting because the idea is you
know Adam alislam our father and his
wife were in paradise and before they
had made the mistake of eating from The
Forbidden tree you know they never
noticed or realized their their their uh
you know the the their private part
right they were they were they were
covered and then the result of them
eating is that they became uncovered so
there's a connection between sin and
Disobedience to God and losing your
clothing losing your modesty losing that
protection Islam really emphasizes
modesty and honor and dignity uh I think
as other
faiths did in the past but no longer do
it becomes the last stronghold to
protect modesty in our modern time yeah
Steve so we went from the surfing with
men to the boundaryless inappropriate
friendships to modeling right now and
then we have to post
now this is another one of his lines
here to post pictures of yourself in
bathing suits this kind of uh goes in
line what we just talk about but he's
also requesting her now to not take
scantly tawdry pictures and specifically
tell my bathing suits and you can just
build on this just uh I mean again it's
they might as well be posting in
lingerie I mean where is the level of
modesty again Islam teaches that your
body's for yourself and to share with
your loved one right and it is an honor
for a man to see his wife right uh not
dressed fully not covered that she
shares his her beauty her skin her
personal intimacy with him it isn't
something for every random person to
look at to fantasize over it's
inappropriate it's against dignity it's
against honor it's against respect and I
think it's completely normal that a man
would not value right if a woman is
showing what she's got for the world
her value has decreased her value isn't
judged by her body but she's making it
that way by using her body as a
commodity to get likes and for what what
is the point why do you want other
people to see your body why do you want
other people to see your beauty what are
you trying to prove
who sets these limits now because at one
point in time if you go back even if you
go back to the beaches here in Chicago
and you look at how 19 20s 30s 40s not
too long ago you would see even in the
the beaches you would see what is
unheard of at this time compared to then
they were the way they were dressed
people they would even give out tickets
if you were not uh that's what we're
feeling too much this this and then and
then the next Generation comes less is
now taken
um even less has taken more has taken
off and then you even have at one point
it was below the knee the skirts and now
you'll see some of even these uh anchors
these uh you'll see on what conservative
talk shows where the dresses of the
ladies even get higher and they're
they're so uncomfortable they're trying
to pull it down and it just but they're
pressured because of the culture and
whatnot to go ahead and dress a certain
way when it's just like uh Trump was
saying I had uh share something about
Trump then I saw a woman interviewed
they said we want to wear we've worn
them for a thousand years why would
anybody tell us not to they want to what
the hell are we getting involved for
in fact it's easier you don't have to
put up makeup look how beautiful
everyone looks wouldn't it be easier
right wouldn't that be easy
I'll tell you if I was a woman I don't
wanna I'm ready darling let's go it's
true
he was like when he got to understand
the uh yeah
he said hey they just get out put it on
and go what leave them alone they've
been doing this so Islam says listen
when you go wow yeah cover up dress
modest yeah your body's a sacred gift
it's not for the world to see but when
you're home
dress up nice dress up whatever your
best you know that you can yeah this
modern culture has the opposite right
when you go out show the world your
beauty when you're home you know don't
don't don't put in any effort
it's backwards backwards we go back to
backwards again and you know the uh
often example given when you had the
women they did the social experiments
where the woman is going down in New
York and she's wearing normal dresses
kind of tight what would be normal and
all the who's and hows that she's
getting you know the provocative speech
for men and then you have the other
woman and she's dressed in hijab
nobody's and that's why Paul says dress
modestly that you may be protected yeah
right it you know Islam recognized as
human nature it doesn't justify that bad
behavior yeah but at the same time you
have a responsibility to set the
standards for yourself don't lower your
standards have some honor and dignity
for yourself when you honor your body
other people will honor it when you
dishonor your body you're giving the
signal for others to dishonor it as well
doesn't justify it but you're giving
that signal and it's inappropriate and
it's wrong as the more you honor
yourself the more you will be honored
and they they used to if you go into
this I mean deeper this is an Islam is a
solution a lot of people
we talk about this they hear this and it
goes with what people naturally agree
with but the whole culture is doing the
opposite and then they tune into the
show they watch us like man I agree with
that yeah this is what they've been
searching for this is what I've been
searching for absolutely absolutely and
that's why we will get attacked for
saying what we say yeah and it's
perfectly okay because they can't harm
us in the least but we're going to stand
up for principles that that frankly uh
are going to protect our own children I
have two beautiful daughters you know
and as a as a father
I would rather be dead
than see my daughter
disrespecting her body and having others
disrespect her body as well and the way
to have her honor her body is just by
being that best example you can be
teaching her to Value yourself that your
body's a sacred gift from God not every
man deserves
to look at you that's why they want to
force women to remove that hijab right
and and dress a modest because they want
to occupy the body of the woman within
their eyes and their mind and their
heart and their lust
but Islam says no your body's not ma my
body's not yours to occupy
right it's not going to be occupied in
the brain of no pervert Yeah you know so
just protect yourself and value yourself
it's not going to be occupied in the
brain of a pervert huh that's it yes
protecting what's uh the most precious
the woman is the most precious that's it
thing that's out there one of the most
precious and you want to protect what
God Almighty has given her and your
responsibility over her so what Jonah is
doing is actually in line with Islam
sound like a Muslim to me yeah Jonah I
like item Jonah Hill if you're listening
you got to consider now
uh looking into Islam look uh Jonah you
got you really gotta respect I mean it
takes a lot of courage and strength to
stay by your principles don't let the
the mob of Hypocrites bring you down man
keep your head up high uh you stood by
principles you were a gentleman in how
you did it and people are are just
showing their own hypocrisy and their
attacks against you and what you're
doing is consistent with the pure
traditional faith of surrendering to God
so we want to invite you to learn more
about Islam uh you know you you have a
community that stands with you on this
issue all right so we finished uh the
model to post pictures of yourself in
bathing suit to post sexual pictures uh
next one moving along we've got a couple
more friendships with women who are in
unstable places and from your wild
recent past Beyond getting a lunch or
coffee or something respectful he's
really laying it down yeah I mean listen
to Muslims this is like normal this is
one-on-one Basics you don't have to be
Muslim like you just have to be rational
and see where this degeneracy is leading
and what path and and what's happening
in the society so you got that you got
that so with unstable friends people
from your past and with the wild side
I mean literally I mean look and he said
beyond he said okay you can have lunch
and coffee sure yeah but but don't don't
cut them off completely look
I think a lot of us as Muslims we grew
up very sheltered alhamdulillah
um but but those of us that that know
what's out there I mean it's it's just
it's insane it is you know as look as
Muslim men we would literally rather die
than commit fornication right Yusuf
Islam he said my Lord jail is more
beloved to me prison is more beloved to
me than falling into fornication and
literally for any Muslim man
um you know it's it's it's the worst
thing that we can imagine happening
whereas how people are living nowadays
it's normal for a woman to sleep with a
different guy every other night there's
no respect for the body there's no
respect for Honor they're destroying
themselves they're ending up empty
feeling used degraded devalued and alone
it's a disaster
um and and that's why he does he just
wants to protect her from that culture
of degeneracy
as Any Man Of Honor would want to
protect his significant other I mean
that's a sign of love as opposed to the
other guy the other guy I believe his
name is Adam don't even mention his name
okay he's not even worthy of his name
being mentioned in our presence the
other guy who's actually inviting men to
go ahead and
a man who doesn't care who sees who
touches who's intimate with his wife
will not enter Paradise God won't even
look at him God will not look at the
youth the man who has no honor for his
wife it is very scary when you look at
the description you have like huge
um when the description of people for
Zina who fall into these um pitfalls and
again there's always hope people can
turn away and of course to turn to Allah
but if if someone falls into this and
doesn't persist and you know the ovens
of people naked and they're being you
know
um going through thank God for those
Traditions brother I would tell you
because growing up in America it's easy
to feel tempted and seduced yeah I'm
grateful for what Islam says about
against Xena fornication I'm grateful
that the Sharia says that if a man in a
Muslim country right is caught
fornicating where people see the
penetration for people
which is impossible it's a lesson but
the punishment right is stoning I'm
grateful for that because maybe a time
comes in life where somebody actually
just genuinely it's not even about a
sexual lust maybe somebody actually
falls in love with a woman he's not
married to
and and to resist love it's even harder
than resisting sexual Temptations to
resist that that that drive you know
within the heart and a person has the
opportunity to fornicate but they read
the Hadith Hadith says literally the
punishment should be stoning this just
shows you how a born is and that's
what's going to stop you it's a strong
deterrent it's a it's a deterrent and
that's what you need you need that
powerful deterrence too you know in in
the legal Theory we studied this in law
school that for a deterrent to be
effective the less probable it is to be
enforced than the higher and more
intense the punishment has to be for it
to have a deterrent effect so for
example if uh you know you get uh
everybody's going to get caught speeding
and the punishment for speeding is ten
dollars people will still speed there's
a high probability of getting caught but
there's also a very low punishment
people will still do it however
if uh the probability of getting caught
speeding is just one percent very small
but the punishment is like death
nobody's gonna speed even if there's a
low chance of getting caught so same
thing in the Islamic principle it's
practically impossible to get convicted
of fornication you literally have to
have four people that have never
publicly sinned you know that are not
considered uh witness the penetration
which is practically about even four
people even 10 people seeing a man and
woman naked in bed together they could
not accuse them of actually committed
fornication if they didn't see the
penetration so the pro the possibility
of that happening is impossible it's
practically impossible but therefore for
it to be strongly deterrent there's a
very strict punishment which is the
stoning and that's a mercy that's a
protection it's to protect you know men
and women when they get tempted they
realize man this is something God hates
so much that in the Bible in the Quran
in the Islamic traditions this is the
punishment that's outlined for it I
should avoid it it's to protect
ourselves to protect our honors yeah to
protect society as a whole right there's
a tuition the family and so on because
the families destroyed the society is
destroyed then you see what's happening
that's it yep that's it and he moves
along so this one also is he's
fulfilling his if he was a Muslim his
Islamic duty of protecting his family
and protecting his spouse well he's not
married here but it's in line it looks
like it's the direction he was going in
he's trying to make this woman his wife
yeah he's setting clear boundaries and
so Jonah Hill it's like he's almost
talking as if he's a Muslim that's it
that's right because these are this is
pretty clear so what he's talking about
is something
now wrapping up uh he says I am Jonah
Hill says I am not the right partner for
you if these things bring you a place of
happiness I support it and there will be
no hard feelings these are my boundaries
from romantic Partnerships my boundaries
with you based on the ways these actions
have hurt our trust so one thing is we
can point with John Hill a lot one thing
we can advise him is
is to really seek out the purpose of
life know why you've been created while
you're here and then you can go ahead
and get into any car that's it you know
I mean the woman's marriage
and get along get out of this uh test
driving you know boyfriend girlfriend
things and make it right with God God
made it easy he made the permissible
easy uh but people make it hard but look
I look his message was so modest and
that's why for me it's insane to see the
level of hate and the accusations
against him because he simply laid out
his requirements of modesty for somebody
he's going to be in a relationship with
and he said if these aren't you know if
you're not okay with these boundaries
then no hard feelings but it just we're
not cut out for each other why is a guy
getting attacked for setting his
personal about is he supposed to lie or
is he supposed to just bend over to the
will of the mob it's insane I think he
was respectful I think he was unfairly
targeted and I think he just reflected
what any person that is connected to the
pure nature that God gave us would
advocate for again know what it's saying
he's a saint no one's saying he's
perfect but he's certainly on the right
trajectory and and we hope he looks into
Islam because guess what the one
community that will stand by you is the
traditional Muslim Community when it
comes to these things and then she
concludes here herself his ex-girlfriend
this is a warning she says to all girls
if your partner is talking to you like
this make an Exit Plan love y'all call
me make an example he's literally saying
we don't need to continue the
relationship she doesn't need an exit
please he's saying these are my these
are what what's important to me and uh
if if if that doesn't Vibe with you all
right no hard feelings we go our
separate ways perfectly innocent and
harmless yeah she would uh do very good
also with looking into Islam so we give
them both an invitation no both listen I
mean Society has deceived a lot of women
about what they need to be happy and
I'll tell you this you know look in life
you you see you know people go through
different phases there's a phase where a
lot of women they want to prioritize
their career they're getting the likes
they're getting their Fame and yeah it's
nice in your 20s and maybe your early
30s by the time you get up into your 40s
and 50s you're gonna wish you had that
family you're gonna wish you had that
man that was just taking care of all of
your financial needs so you can live
comfortably at home raise those
beautiful children you're gonna wish you
had those kids and those beautiful
grandkids that looked up to you and a
lot of women because of modern feminism
are going to be deprived of that and
they're going to regret it and hate it
so much as they grow older what does she
have now okay so she had somebody who
was giving her who was straight with her
said if you do this we can move forward
and actually they were healthy so
healthy suggestions or boundaries that
he was setting or things that he was
expressing that he wanted right for a
partner he moved on she's obviously if
she was happy he's still occupying his
face yeah yeah she's not happy she's
clearly miserable if she had moved on in
her life if she was happy she would not
have posted she would not have posted
that you know it's somebody who's too
busy enjoying their life doesn't have
time to create drama for others you know
moving on and being happy is the best
you know success so the fact is there
there's clearly issues she's struggling
with may God guide her really make that
guide her because to go to see your
ex-spouse or ex-partner move on maybe
get married maybe have a child and to
feel the need to bring up years old
personal messages we're just saying
listen I don't want my wife having
inappropriate relationships with men or
even hanging out with women that have
destructive Lifestyles and posting
scantly clad photos of herself and if
you want to do that I support you it
just were not cut out for a intimate
relationship to go after him for that
years later shows she's really not in a
good place and my heart you know feels
for because I believe she's also the
victim we like to be victims here the
victim of a society that deceives people
as to what will give them happiness and
success and Society right now is
misleading people it's deceiving people
it's it's the jalic really in nature and
the only guidance is the guidance from
God that's never been changed and that
is the Holy Quran that revives the
original message of Moses of Jesus uh
peace be upon them that God is one that
we should value our body it's a sacred
trust we treat it with honor that we
should value Intimate Relationships that
we should be aware of going with those
that may misguide us it's a beautiful
Universal message and it's the only
thing that can quench our thirst and
give us peace that's it that's it
otherwise you're fumbling in the dark
you're making it's your whole life is
subjective to the rules of society which
change according to the times and
people's whims and desires you obviously
what do you call this other woman who
actually accepted the terms she accepted
so I don't know if they ended up getting
married what it but they had a child
and she's what do you call her nutcase
because she's she's obviously in line he
probably went and gave her the same
guidelines and they're together and and
that's what's ultimately going to bring
people happiness when they learn so
she's got a partner now exactly exactly
you know again
frankly I think uh you know many two men
of honorable many two people of Honor uh
you know relationships will not survive
if people don't even know what a man and
a woman is and the different roles and
different responsibilities we need
feminine women that are paired up with
masculine men that protect each other
that shelter each other and to stay away
from all forms of indecency and
distraction and immorality which
destroys families and destroys societies
and destroys people's Souls at the end
of the day and you don't have anything
out there because you have like Islam
where you have intelligent God-fearing
women who are sick of being used and
abused by men who are sick of you know
just following the cultural norms they
actually are coming to Islam so many I
mean so many women that that had all the
quote unquote sorry freedoms right of of
that western side gives them where they
were out in the clubs where they're
wearing the mini skirts where they're
sleeping around different guys where
they're drinking partying living up
doing everything that that Instagram
life shows you life should be like they
found a void and empty and they traded
that for hijab for nikob for modesty for
a righteous spouse so it happened so
much why are so many women in the West
in fact women in the west are converting
like four times more than the man why
because Society in the west really
oppresses women and debases them and
humiliates them and uses them and abuses
them and that is why so many women are
actually Choosing by their own free will
to give up the miniskirt for the hijab
to give up in modesty for modesty there
is you know in in my field we you speak
to a lot of different people I mean I
know woman what led them to Islam was
how Islam prohibited adultery how Islam
prohibited fornication how they found
that the lifestyle of fornication didn't
give them Peace of Mind tranquility and
they loved the grounding and the
morality that Islam gave them so you as
Jonah Hill if you're tuning in you're
watching this uh obviously he didn't put
this out for the public to to see it was
put out there so you can see how people
now some people even probably amongst
this closed Circle may be turning down
on them he's being called all these
different names so are you living for
the pleasure of the people or if you
have any ounce I mean like I I don't
believe there's any any person that's
truly an atheist but because they made a
left might have left the man-made
religion and they just you know give up
all together but if he truly is sincere
now and he is a man's man and he don't
care about what are people going to say
because the only thing that a lot of
times keeps people from looking into
Islam is because what's my friends going
to say Society maybe my manager maybe
it's not good for my career or whatnot
but any person that really truly looks
into Islam will see that it's indeed
from the creators of Heaven and Earth it
doesn't take a rocket scientist to look
at the evidence to look at the Quran to
read it one time through and actually
um we'll uh at the end people go to the
dean show.com and then get a free copy
of the Quran
uh I don't think he has to do much
homework to to find that this system
this way of life complete way of life is
indeed not just another a religion
that's out there uh it's pure it's
unchanged and my advice to him actually
don't buckle men don't give in to the
Mob you didn't do anything wrong don't
apologize for saying what Any Man Of
Honor would say but rather amplify and
refine it understand where that came
from and why Islam teaches the exact
things that you are looking for in a
spouse and a partner and get to know
your lord man through the only word
that's never been changed the Holy Quran
the Quran pick up a Quran or go to the
deanshow.com we'll get you a copy of
that
um and others if they like some uh free
uh not free but um Muslim legal advice
yeah Muslim legal.org hit us up alhamdul
we're doing a lot of work to make peace
between people we do Islamic mediation
arbitration we've done even criminal
defense help those wrongfully accused it
happens way too often so if you need a
legal advice you need legal guidance
muslimlegal.org we're here to help oh
thank you very much thank you Eddie's
good inshallah this can be a benefit to
so many
men likewise
and sisters this is and I'm so excited
so grateful to Allah to be standing
right here at the dean center that is
being established in Tampa by brother
Eddie from the dincha we are so excited
that he shows in Tampa to be this Hub
and Center for dawa not just locally
alhamdulillah where we can host seminars
programs dawa activities there's enough
space for a school gymnasium Masala and
a studio that can inshallah reach people
globally to share the beauty of Islam
we're so excited to have this
established here locally in Tampa and I
want to encourage you all do what you
can to help complete this project and
make it a reality and I invite you all
to join me in supporting the Center of
America for all of us to share the
beauty of the dean with all Humanity
[Music]
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you